[Music]
all right this is something that uh this
happened in Germany uh there's a German
restaurant worker and he uh falsely
claimed to be a doctor he started making
online ads for a girth enhancing medical
procedure I'll take it yeah dude I'm in
you want it you're in I'm in dude me and
Anthony we're in you mean like does it
with surgery he can make it three oh is
he just like trying to secretly suck
some dick on the side
I'll make your girth bigger by letting
me yeah I'll get you
big let me wrap my lips around
it hey German accent though German
accent though that's the guy right there
that's it so be the doctor hey hey okay
so you're a restaurant worker you want
some hot dick in your mouth and you're
like thinking of a master plan to come
up with a lot of consensual penis m to
get big grow consent I'm I'm a waiter my
trade yeah but then but you have to
devise a plan you're gay
motivated you have to deise a plan to
how to get your lips around dick how do
you suck that dick how do I suck that
dick this is just Fantasy by the way you
don't even have to speak German just
show us the mouth no speak German like
that too much teeth moan moan in German
don't time how do they moan it go ahead
go ahead just moan moan in German and
then show me how you suck them dick they
go w do that cuz they always say hello
cuz they're very polite people right and
then they ask um if I'm talking to a
patron I'll be like can you not film me
dude I wasn't filming film right here I
don't think they would say that yeah yes
they wouldn't say that but they would go
to you talk to
patreons and not patrons is that what I
said like if I'm talking to a patreon
you're talking to the
platform cuz I have a following at this
point yeah I
go uh and then I'll I'll just have a
regular ad on my on like a website like
a landing page and I'll be like are you
are oh [__] I don't know to do that
German accent hold on
say go like this it helps go like this
it helps
uh are you ready oh no know that's your
reset you travel quick dude cleans your
pet say V again
say yeah I got to do a more cleans your
pet give me oh [__] I don't even know
what um what are your other goto to help
I don't know
dude
um yeah keep that energy conval German
is hard keep the energy of G yeah yeah
yeah um stick to the words that you know
for sure okay yeah z
z see I don't even that's good that was
good that was good that was good commit
just commit you're not committing at all
um you
know so bad quits on where did your
confidence
go you quit on you hey but really you
quit on
what mean three
in three ining him so hard rather he
rather hear definition that's good
that's good that's good the the uh the
acceptable girth is around 3
in
circumference when I say circumference
that's too many syllables yeah a um so
like Ryan what happened dude all right
I'll go on with it so he um so it was a
real thing that he would actually do
these ads saying that he could increase
your dick girth and uh and very cheaply
too and the way that he would do it is
he would inject silicone into your dick
and people were okay with this hey that
actually probably works I inject a
silicone it's it's a synthetic rubber
okay that we will inject at the
base I like the evil Goblin look after
that's you're very German yeah I feel
like we got to Rift you got to realize
how bad I do it to get your confidence
back who's the bad guy in awesome powers
Dr Evil like you're going that route
yeah I'm going sometimes it goes Indian
it's okay I don't even have an Indian go
Indian you're mix you're mixing styles
of the injection at the girl the
injection point will be on
two below the
base paint they don't do the metric
system they don't oh [__] you're right
Jesus Christ I'd probably skip ad yeah
just skip yeah
you're this guy engag me all what
happens is um that is a thing that they
do they do inject uh penises with stuff
but it's not usually this type of
silicone uh this is kind of like the the
cheap hack way that does not even really
work yeah it's like when people try to
inject their biceps they look all buff
but it's like just like water but there
is a danger if you do it incorrectly way
and the way that he did it'll enter your
bloodstream and then die and that's
exactly what happened to somebody he
killed somebody was it his first
customer I hope he we don't know if it's
his first uh but somebody did go to him
and they got the silicone into their
dick it entered their bloodstream and
died a horrible death because what
happens is when silicone enters your
bloodstream your all of your organs fail
one after the other and organ failure is
possibly one of the worst most painful
ways to go oh soag dick stomach shut
down like everything just off off off
off off yes how many days did you have a
big old dick for yeah did you get to use
it did it say in the article that's a
Nick dunk question did he live his dream
I think two days and does he did he die
with his dick in his
hand or at least both hands maybe his
arm that sucks you get a new dick you
don't even get to use it and you die you
barely use it it probably didn't look
very good cuz you know how these things
are when they inject that way it just
looks like a freaking warp I don't know
how these things are I'll show you it's
not going to be you know what this is
about but you want a new dicks I want a
visual you want the big old dick we see
a lot of bad visuals over here silicone
eject oh I don't want a dick that bad
imagine in two like you're oh my God
thing's huge I I might call this number
what's the number oh what is that it
looks like a human being it looks like a
dude wearing a d wearing a dude yeah
what is that dude wearing a dude it
looks like a dude that he has a dude is
a dick it look like a person why
wait what the [__] that looks like
elephant Titus that looks like his balls
are bigger than his dick anyway that
[__] looks like this that looks like
three balls yeah that's the what why
dude diet's dick is small huh yeah on a
good day dietrix is like that's an
overwhelmingly powerful
[__] yeah it looks like of the Gods I
see sack I see sack everywhere where the
[__] they look like they have
elephantitis dud that thing is huge is
that that's silicone yeah that fool
looks like he's carrying a CH
another human like I said he's holding a
little [__] baby but that's a
silicone dick right there that is yeah
how can you fit
it that's bigger than a [__] dude
told you bro it looks like a missile
launcher dude what is that dude wait one
more time that looks like an eggplant
like a like a really big egg that guy
looked like he [__] plucked silocone
from the
rainforest did it's like he's holding a
tree TR yeah what the [__] is that a
silicone di yeah because that's the guy
who died that fool looks like he's
[__] shaking a piglet up and down I'm
still looking at it first of all when
are you going to find a matching vagina
I need to see this real fast this is the
biggest dick I've ever seen that looks
like a
child I told
you down though he's holding a human
being you know what's weird about it is
he got [__] the guy [__] he has no balls
it just looks like it just looks like
stem in head cuz you know there's
nothing he can do about his balls yeah
that's crazy find the counterpart though
like where are you gonna find the
counterpart when Hur he probably has to
hold it that fool looks like a farmer
who's proud of his squash yeah that's
and then he passed away two days later
uh I don't actually know the amount of
days but it in later was fairly quick 2
Ines later he died 2 in later what
compels someone to want a dick so big I
pay 50 bucks for that you want to see
what it looks like when you actually
have comp from it and they try to save
you yeah yeah yeah show me I dare you I
dare you this can
only you want to see it the fans will
just see facial
reaction wait what is that did it
explode is that really what yeah okay
get that out non-verbal non-verbal
non-verbal so don't ever inject anything
in your dicks please show show us we
need facial reaction good Lord all right
for the fans dud oh my God oh my what
what oh oh my God that's a pee peee that
not a Halloween decoration it looks like
Stater Brothers flank steak let me
see top middle no [__] way what the
[__] dude why they have to light it like
that it like bright red what what was
the Google search so that fans at home
can also feel our pain um it's silicone
injected dick just find the red oneck
neon red you'll be like it exploded yeah
so guys if you have any feelings of
insufficiency it's not worth it don't go
down this path NSFW it ends badly just
wear a strap on yes it's a little gay
also there's no qualified doctor on the
planet that would actually do this
procedure it's incorrect have you guys
seen those dick extenders excuse me SE
them seen them I I wear them SE them no
wearing them there's like these like
dick tips that you can wrap around on
top of your dick what does that like to
make your dick bigger you could just
it's almost like what are these platform
shoes yeah it looks like it looks like
you put your dick in another dick makes
it bigger seen Dick Stoppers not kidding
no it's a dick stopper so just in case
you're going too deep on your [__] it
is like there a dick sto yeah it like
stops your dick from going too deep I
don't have that problem at all dude I
don't I won't need that product thank
you just put it on on the base of your
dick and it's it acts as a there's a
ster one there's a stop I thought that
was to keep you from not coming too fast
no no no there number one that keeps
from going too deep no no no so
sometimes [__] are like hormonal and
you can't go as deep right and so then
you put the stop that's a big problem I
don't have going that deep I'm not
talking for myself this is a
problem look it up Ryan it exists it
looks all right dick extendos I only
know about that because um my buddy says
that he has that but I'm like probably
it's probably full [__] but I mean this
is the most like popular thing but is
that what you're talking about nope oh
my goodness that's not it that looks
like a dick that got accident need a
[__] that's like a dick Communication
System yeah it's like if looks like a
dick at a call center it's like
aing that's a dick who's like telling
other dicks what to do that's a dick
that goes like this sorry I
lied I told him about the sorry I lied
oh but I didn't say who it was okay
okay